Piers, we're human. We have hearts. It
doesn't matter what color or religion
you are. When you see those images,
Piers, do they not rip YOUR HEART OUT?
PIERS, DO THEY NOT MAKE YOU WEEP? WHAT
CRIME DID THIS PERSON COMMIT THAT
JUSTIFIES THIS SORT of destruction? And
I will say this, I will not allow the
tragedy of these innocent victims in
Bondi Beach to be politicized. We should
do that
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a masjid and community center in Norway,
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a sadaqa jariya
for you because every person that comes
a step closer to Allah through your
donation, you will inshallah be reaping
the rewards. Click the link and donate
what you can.
>> As-salamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh, brothers and sisters and dear
friends. Hope you guys are well,
inshallah. I'm here with Sheikh Hazem.
As-salamu alaykum, Sheikh. How are you
doing? Wa alaykum as-salam wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. As-salamu
alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh
everyone. Fantastic. Alhamdulillah. You
are with your favorite reaction video
Sheikh here.
Sheikh Hazem alhamdulillah leads the
Salah project in Salah Pro,
alhamdulillah, guys. So, yes, he's here
today. We're going to watch a video of
Piers Morgan and brother
Sami. Sami. Sami, inshallah. A beautiful
beautiful brother. May Allah bless him,
inshallah. Very well spoken. We're going
to watch the video, inshallah, and see
what we can make out of it, inshallah.
It's pertaining to our hero brother
Ahmed Al Hamed,
and subhanallah, how they are trying to
politicize this issue and
>> because they all call him Ahmed Al
Hamed.
>> [laughter]
>> Exactly. He's a Muslim, but they they
are trying to I mean,
it's so interesting. Benjamin Netanyahu
thought he was Jewish. He praised him,
praised him, praised him. Now, I think
he's got a dilemma now. Yes. Yes.
[laughter] Yes. He's in a moral
conundrum. Yes, okay. So, let's watch
the video, inshallah, with Piers Morgan
and these Zionist criminals. Well, this
is what we hear, but honestly, I'm not
going to entertain any excuses for
terrorism. There is no excuse, and once
you go down that track of saying, "Oh,
well, you know, they had it coming to
them and it's their fault because their
government you are playing into the
hands of the terrorists and rewarding
them for the utter mayhem and bloodshed
that destroyed a lovely party in Bondi
Beach, killed a 10-year-old girl, and
killed, you know, 14 other people at
least, 15, I think, and has left
Australia just reeling. I mean, that is
the worst terrorist attack in
Australia's history, and it's Sydney and
Bondi Beach are just such peaceful
places for a war a world away to come to
the shores of Australia is beyond
shocking, and you cannot excuse it in
any way.
>> No, I completely agree with that. The
Okay, firstly, I don't know the context
of what she's talking about. I don't
know if she's for or against, but no
one's She's against. She's against.
>> Is she? Cuz I don't know the context. I
don't know if she's talking about those
who are attacking the Australian
government. No, no, she's talking about
the actual terrorism that happened. But
look, let's ask let's ask a question.
The question The question that needs to
be asked
is the act that happened in
uh Australia, is it
Islamic act? Does the Has it got a place
in Islam? Does Islam allow it? The
question You're right, Sheikh. The
question is this. There are two Muslims
doing two acts. Which one belong to
Islam? Well, so-called Muslim who know
nothing about them. We know nothing
about them.
>> nothing about them. Not only that, let's
suppose they they are Muslim. No
problem. Yes, okay. There are two.
There's two individuals who who are
committing heinous act killing innocent
people. Then you've got a Muslim who's
coming to save the lives. Now, the
question we need to ask is the
following. Which one is following the
true Islam? Is there anywhere in our
text because we want to go back to
reaction video. We don't want to be too
long, but
in Islam, does it say anywhere to kill
innocent people? So, this is take us to
the to to the Quran. Whoever
keep
keep alive as if he has kept alive for
all humanity.
So, we have evidence to to to back up
that the man who did the rescuing is
from Islam. Yes.
>> Is there anywhere in our text that those
two criminals And nobody likes to
mention that he's a Muslim. They mention
him by name, but as a Muslim, nobody.
You You watch all the news media, all
the media, all the news, Ahmed Al Hamed,
Ahmed Al Hamed,
but Muslim, no, no. It's interesting.
So, when a Muslim does good, it's not
his religion, but when he does something
bad, it is his religion. Let's go to the
video. Okay. Okay.
The complexity, of course, of the
narrative around this attack is that
many people reacted, as they always do
when there's an attack by Islamic
extremists, by saying, "We've got to get
all the Muslims out. This is the
problem. It's about Islam as a religion.
There's too many of them radicalized.
They hate the West. They want to kill
everybody." And then we discover that
the hero, who is one of the great heroes
that I've ever seen in any situation
ever, this guy, you know, who just risks
his life, and apparently his last words
to the people he was with was, "I think
I'm going to die. Please tell my family
I did this to save others" or something
like that. Incredible. And he goes to
risk his life, gets shot repeatedly in
the process, is thankfully, we think,
going to be okay. He's in hospital. Um
but he's not just an Australian hero.
He's a global hero. And yet he's Ahmed
Al Hamed. He's a He's came from Syria as
an immigrant to Australia. He's a Muslim
himself. And so, you know, if you have a
kick all the Muslims out view of this,
well, what do you do about the hero? He
saved so many lives because he's the
very type of immigrant from a Muslim
country like Syria that many of those
who espouse that view would say
shouldn't have been allowed in Australia
in the first place. So, did you did you
notice one thing?
>> No.
He disarmed the person. Yes. The
perpetrator
The perpetrator is disarmed. That's it.
He points the gun towards him, but his
heart couldn't allow him to I'll be
honest if I was in that situation, I
would shoot that guy. Yeah. Straight
away. No question asked. But look at
him. He disarmed him because this man
hadn't didn't have it in him to kill.
On the contrary, what he had in him is
to save life, not to waste life, even
though that that man was a legal a
legitimate target to be to be hurt.
Exactly. And I believe the other
shooter, his son, for example, that guy
who disarmed was his father. The son on
the bridge was shooting at him. And I
believe that son, who is a Muslim, if he
if he somehow I say, "Okay, he probably
thought it's probably another Jew."
Well, I believe if he knew he was a
Muslim, he'd say, "He's a He's a
hypocrite, munafiq. He's He's attacking
us." He would have still shot him.
Exactly. So, it just shows the extreme
mindset that they have. And he, the the
hero, the Muslim hero, brother Ahmed, he
represents Islam. There is nothing in
our Islamic literature that shows or
supports what those two heinous
terrorists done.
>> Yeah, operation Islam came to combat
oppression. The Prophet Sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam, he did what we call
the Council of Fudul. This council
helped for Fudul. He said, "And this is
actually it's a pre-Islamic council."
Pre-Islamic council. The Prophet
Sallallahu alayhi wa sallam said, "If I
was to be called to help for Fudul, I
will answer I will answer it." The
reason being because it used to go to
support the oppressed. Islamically, this
heinous crime this heinous crime has got
nowhere to be placed in Islam. You
cannot place it in Islam. You cannot say
Yeah, so-called that he's done it. And
that lady who
whom she said that that was the worst
that happened. Let me Let us remind her
that it was the Australian that killed
the more than
in New Zealand. It was Australian and
that. We didn't say that all the
Australians are far right or all the
Australians are the same. Exactly. And
not only that, in the Quran, Allah says,
"Come together for righteousness."
And that guy, he came together saving
the He saved Jewish people's lives. Just
like the Ottomans did when Israel
when Isabella and Ferdinand were
persecuting and forcing the Jews and
Muslims to accept Christianity, they ran
to the lands of the Ottomans. So, he's
doing what the Muslim empires done
before. Why is Morocco full of Jews?
Exactly.
>> Because because they ran there and they
opened their houses to them. They They
They accepted them.
>> Muslims were persecuting saving Jews on
the persecution because of Christians
who were persecuting them. That's where
you anti-Semitism comes from. Who kind
of
Where did the Jewishness flourished? In
Andalusia. In Andalusia. Exactly. Let's
carry on, inshallah. And brother Sami's
going to come with some knockout blows,
so guys, keep tuned in, inshallah. For a
very long time, that there is a clear
distinction between Jewishness and
Zionism, that there is a clear
distinction between Jewishness and the
state of Israel, and that the state of
Israel does not act on behalf of or
speak on behalf of all Jews by
absolutely no means. It is the It is the
state of Israel and its outriders.
>> you mean? Do you mean the government? I
mean, you because you say the state of
Israel, that that is the whole of
Israel. Right. So, I presume what you're
what you're saying is that whatever the
current government is any given time, a
bit like the government in the UK or the
government in America, doesn't
necessarily represent more than a slight
majority of the country, right? They
They win an election. Maybe half nearly
half the country votes against them. So,
is that what you're saying? Because when
you say the state of Israel at the time,
you could be implying all of Israel.
Well, okay, here we come to a
distinction, Piers, cuz I watch your
show regularly, and I know that you
Okay, so I just want to cut this here,
and I think Piers is right. Yeah, at the
end of the day, he should distinguish,
and I don't think he did it, but yes,
you cannot the Jews and the Zionists are
two separate entities. It's like coming
and saying ISIS are Muslims. Of course,
they're not. Do you get it? And not only
that, for Sheikh, one thing that I'm
missing out, those heinous perpetrators,
these two terrorists who attacked these
Jews, killed 15 Jewish people, innocent
people, yeah? If you think about it,
they have the same ideology as Zionists,
collective punishment.
They're like, "No, they're responsible
for Gaza." Yes, most We don't know their
motive, but most likely it's that. And
that's the same ideology as Zionists. We
collectively punish all the Gazans for
what? They claim Hamas done. But
honestly, to be honest with you, it's
not like
I don't know, but it's weird. It all of
this kind of thing is so weird. Yeah, it
is. It is. It is. The
selection of the day as if they pre-
They had pre-knowledge of Yeah, his name
was searched in Israel.
>> In Israel. Not only even in America, his
name was Yes. Yes. Yes. I genuinely
believe that I don't believe in a lot of
I don't believe in a lot of
Yeah, there's a lot of things that he
was an IDF soldier. This is all This is
all nonsense. Okay. I genuinely believe
that intelligence services know these
people and what they're going to do.
They stop them based on their agenda,
and they let them go based on their
agenda. I believe they knew they were
going to do this. They said, "Shh. You
know like the stand down order in
October 7th?" Yes. They said, "Let them
do it. It works for our agenda." That's
how vile they are. Now, here's a bit
where brother Sami comes and knocks out
the whole scene. Here's the video,
inshallah. Let's watch this. Absolutely
epic. try to suddenly decide, "I'm going
to be ISIS and kill every Jew I can
see."
Piers, thanks very much for having me. I
think you've tried to bring the
discussion to the crux of the issue. I
think first and foremost, there's no
justification for what happened. It's a
heinous and disgusting crime that took
place, and my thoughts and prayers go
out to the families of the victims
themselves. And I think that when you
with that you're asking is are the
events in Gaza influencing in any way
whatsoever the rise in anti-Semitism and
indeed the potential for these acts to
take place. Well, that's partly it. I
mean, I would say that it's it's it's a
double-pronged question. One is that,
which is the current events of the last
2 years, have they made it more or less
safe to be Jewish around the world? But
secondly, this was all going on for a
long time before. I mean, ISIS and other
groups like it were attacking and
targeting Jews for several decades in
this century. It's been a rising tide of
anti-Semitism and violence against Jews
in the last 20 odd years. So, it's
two-pronged. One, it was going on a long
time before this. And has the war in in
a horrible way been a catalyst for it to
be accelerated? And I and I think that
you've hit the nail on the head. Okay,
just before we go to brother Sami. Okay,
he knocked him out. Yes, Sheikh, ISIS
has killed more Muslims than they have
ever. Like some some Name name me one
Jewish person that was killed by ISIS. I
mean, if they if they if they come and
say the one Australian was they had ISIS
flag, this would be the only instance
where you can say that. But before that
They were in Iraq and they were in
Syria.
And we know that Syria has got a border
with with Israel.
Name me one name
list name list name one soldier one
individual that was killed by ISIS. You
will not find it. You will not find it.
They target Muslims. They target anybody
who differs to their ideology. They have
an ideology. Now, you can be a Muslim,
you can be an Imam, you can be a
scholar. They killed so many scholars.
The reason why because the scholars were
against what they were doing. So, they
kind of like sacrificed them.
So, isn't that important that the Muslim
scholars and the public and lay Muslims,
YouTubers like myself, etc. spoke
against ISIS. Yes. However, when it
comes to Zionists, you don't need to say
the same with the Israelis. They don't
see they all support them. Yeah,
Jonathan is there to defend it. Exactly.
Let's carry on inshallah brother Sami
burying these guys. You know, when you
bring up ISIS who killed far more
Muslims than any other religion on this
earth, the huge victims you know the
numbers of victims that were committed
by ISIS. I remember when ISIS used to
say that oh, we're going to go towards
Israel and the like and there was this
famous meme that said, "Okay, but you
guys are in Iraq and Syria, Israel is
that way. Why do you keep killing all
these Muslims over here?" The reason why
I mention this is that when you look at
the world as it is today, think about
what everybody is seeing on their phones
on a daily basis. They're seeing
6-year-old Sidra with her legs blown off
and the blast of the bomb means that her
corpse is hanging on the wall inside
Gaza itself. And then we have people
coming out and saying this is justified,
this is a war, casualties happen in war.
We see Hind Rajab, a 6-year-old girl,
who's in a car desperately calling for
help saying, "I'm scared. My family
around me are dead." The ambulance comes
to rescue her, the Israelis bomb the
ambulance, and she dies surrounded by
the corpses of her family in the cold.
You see Reem, a 5-year-old girl, being
hugged by her grandfather, "Ruh ruh, the
soul of my soul." And everybody is
looking at these images one by one and
the destruction. And Shifa Hospital,
where a certain ex-IDF spokesman goes in
and makes up a video and tries to show
that there is some sort of terrorism
that is taking place and the like that
somehow justifies what's happening to
the Palestinians themselves. And the
reality is that Piers, this does create
this I didn't interrupt you. If you
could give This coward. You know this
coward. He's not even speaking about
him. He's saying an IDF soldier.
He's getting triggered because he's a
spokesman he's a spokesperson for the
IDF. Yes, but he's not even talking
about him. He's talking about the guy
who went and saw some Arabs
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday Monday,
Tuesday, he said that's the names of the
the Hamas operatives. Look how he's
getting triggered. He's not even talking
about him. You know he's he's so guilty.
You know when somebody comes and said,
"Oh, yeah, someone committed murder."
Well, no, no, I didn't. I'm not talking
about you. He's talking about you. It
shows the self
guilt that he has that he's thinking
he's talking about him.
Jonathan, just speak up and wait a
minute. For a while to speak, my dear
friend. You will have
the right to talk. You will have the
right to talk.
But if I could just finish, Piers, let
him finish. Let [laughter] him finish.
Let him finish, please. Piers, be
relaxed. The image is something
I can't If if if you don't mind, just 1
second. Jonathan, you will have time to
speak. You've been here many more times
than I have. The reality is that when
people are seeing all of these images in
America, in Paris, in Berlin and the
like and they're asking Piers, they're
saying, "What crime did that child
commit?" You were with Tucker Carlson
Piers the other day who said to you,
"What crime did that child commit that
she should be killed?" What crime did
the child, 6-year-old, who's now in
Doha, have been evacuated from Gaza, who
has three limbs blown off and has only
two fingers left in hand, what crime did
she commit whereby she should have been
bombed and been in this particular
situation that she finds herself in? And
when they turn on Piers Morgan on Sense
It and Piers, by the way, I will say
your tweet yesterday was phenomenal when
you called him the Bondi hero trying to
cut the crossroads in which people were
trying to stoke hatred and the like. But
when people come on and they turn on the
news and they find justifications for
what's happening. They find people
saying, "Listen, it is what it is. You
just have to get over it." It's natural
for hatred to fester in such hearts that
results in a heightened sense of hatred,
not just anti-Semitism, but Islamophobia
and hate against people around the
world. What was magnificent about what
Ahmed Alnaouq did? He rejected that
hatred. He rejected that hatred that
festered in people's hearts. He said
this is not the world I want to be part
of. This is not the world as it should
be. I believe in a better world, even if
it is these wretched individuals who
claim to be Muslim who are shooting Jews
who are innocently celebrating their
Hanukkah. I reject a world where this is
Muslim versus Jew. I believe in a world
where there is genuine humanity. And now
that is the video that's going viral.
That's the video Piers that you spread.
That's what you called him the Bondi
hero. He's given hope where the Israelis
and the extremists on all religions were
decimating that hope. When we see those
images of those 80% of Gaza destroyed,
Piers. And you're seeing it through the
images and the UN resolutions keep
getting vetoed. The ICC says arrest the
war criminals and we receive news that
the British government wants to defund
ICC because they want to remove the
Netanyahu arrest warrant. The ICJ says
there's a genocide. Piers, I'll just
finish on this point. Piers, we're
human. We have hearts. It doesn't matter
what color or religion you are. When you
see those images, Piers, do they not rip
YOUR HEART OUT? PIERS, DO THEY NOT MAKE
YOU WEEP? AND WHAT CRIME DID THIS PERSON
COMMIT THAT JUSTIFIES THIS SORT of
destruction? And I will SAY THIS, I WILL
NOT allow the tragedy of these innocent
victims in Bondi Beach to be
politicized. We should do them We do
them a disservice You can actually You
can actually You know what? You can wait
as I did over the appalling scenes on
October the 7th.
>> Okay. Any last word Sheikh? I mean, for
me I believe that was an absolute
>> [clears throat]
>> powerful, emotional
>> Absolutely. Absolutely. and even some
Jews came on the day to the place where
it happened and they said, "This is not
going to be politicized. You're not
going to take advantage of it." And
that's exactly what they Even the ex
even the ex
prime minister of
of Australia, he told Yeah, he told him
Netanyahu sticking his nose out of our
politics.
The thing about it, let's finish on
this. What's happened is un-Islamic.
It's got no place in Islam. Islam does
not does not kind of like make
discourses or condone these acts.
And
it shouldn't have happened. There were
innocent people having some nice time
and
>> [gasps]
>> Yeah. Exactly. Some crazy No, not crazy.
Some We don't look, to be honest with
you, until the the Australian Federal
Police finish their their investigation,
I think everybody we shouldn't do like
what Netanyahu does. Every time he jumps
on on a wagon, it makes him look guilty.
I mean, that's it, guys. Nothing else
needs to be said inshallah. Till next
time. Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh. May Allah bless brother
Sami. Done a fantastic job there. And
Piers Morgan, we're not going to give
him any credit because if he thinks he's
just going to come and, you know, be on
the winning team whatever it is,
changes. No, we don't We don't forget.
We don't We don't forget what happened
with Gaza. We're never going to forget.
Never going to forgive him, Piers.
Assalamualaikum warahmatullahi
wabarakatuh.